béatrice baylet bonjour bonjour madame
cupide bonjour à toutes les auditrices
et auditeurs et à toutes les
téléspectatrices et téléspectateurs
puisque je sais que cette émission est
filmé et bonjour jean philippe m'ont
tous amis moutoussamy bonjour madame
cupidon vous êtes le suppléant de
béatrice baylet béatrice baylet
secrétaire fédéral de la fédération
socialiste de martinique qui se
présentent à ce scrutin des élections
législatives est bien dans la
circonscription du centre à leur
première question pourquoi vous
présentez-vous à ce scrutin nous nous
présentons parce qu'aujourd'hui il ya un
moment démocratique par lequel nous
pouvons faire porter nos idées nous
pouvons faire porter aussi des idées et
les revendications des martiniquaises et
des martiniquais et de ce côté là
philippe vient nourrir nos réflexions
mais également nos combats et parce que
en l'occurrence philippe et ouvriers
agricoles je vais lui dire je vais le
laisser dire d'ailleurs ce qui revient
les hanter oui je suis ouvrier agricole
moi je gérais copé
représenter les gens dans la précarité
dans la vraiment dans la misère parce
que les ouvriers agricoles mais pas que
il ya des gens vraiment qu'ils
n'arrivent pas à joindre les deux bouts
et frau choix avec béatrice bel et je
pense que nous pourrons si nous sommes
élus faire un travail formidable avec
ces gens là parce que
vraiment il y aura une crise concernant
ces gens là alors justement alors on va
rentrer dans le détail un peu quelles
seraient vos deux ou trois projets
prioritaires que vous défendriez sur le
territoire globalement si vous étiez élu
à l'assemblée nationale noté ce matin
j'ai été sur j'étais dans une radio
concurrente sympa concurrentes une autre
radio au françois et j'ai rencontré
parce que je ne pouvais pas passer sans
aller les voir j'ai rencontré aussi ses
salariés qui sont en grève sur
le carrefour market du françois qui
m'ont donné des frissons et j'en ai
aussi quand je vous en parle parce
qu'ils sont à plus de 100 jours de grève
sans salaire il y à une crise et une
urgence sociale dans ce pays il ya une
urgence sociale en france à telle
enseigne que vous le savez le ministre
de l'écologie de l'économie vient de
demander aux patrons d'augmenter les
salaires face à 4 5% d'inflation alors
imaginez ce que ça peut être en
martinique aujourd'hui nous avons des
combats à mener avec une urgence
économique une urgence sociale une
urgence écologique une urgence
démocratique parce que nous devons
relever et prendre toute la mesure du
signal qui a été donnée le 23 avril
c'est-à-dire au second tour de la
présidentielle par les antillais et les
ultramarins les dix ultramarins en
général nous ce que nous venons ses
portes et ses voies être la bouche de
ses voix être de véritables
représentants et sur le centre quelles
seraient les priorités sachant que le
centre atlantique et peut être
confrontés à des problématiques plus
spécifiques il y à des problématiques de
pauvreté un donc je parlais de l'urgence
sociale aujourd'hui avec le programme de
la nouvelle union populaire écologique
et sociale nous portons l'idée de
l'augmentation immédiate du smic à 1500
euros net ça c'est déjà une première
priorité qui touchera évidemment toute
la population nous avons également une
priorité en matière écologique et là sur
ce point là je vais laisser philippe
harlé alors jeudi philippe parce que
tout le monde l'appelle philippe sueur
sur la question de l'écologie et de
l'agriculture et notamment son manche je
suppose en tant qu'ouvrier agricole je
suppose que la question de l'emploi
zoomant à la chlordécone c'est un
dossier qui vous interpellent
particulièrement qui m'était appel mais
je connais bien ce dossier là parce que
étant membre du collectif des ouvriers
agricoles nous avons
fait pas mal de fichiers avec les
ouvriers agricoles et avoue dix ans ça
j'ai les larmes aux yeux parce que
franchement lorsqu'on veut la souffrance
de ces gens là les maladies qui est
plutôt chlordécone
fauche 20 ça donne le frisson parce que
il y en a qui ont des descentes
d'organes
des amputations des concerts de tous
bords et franchement je me présente aux
côtés de béatrice et des recettes c'est
surtout parce que tout le monde ignore
pas que l'os est ce un bassin de
l'agriculture et ce chaos je n'ai
vraiment claude est connue et nous en
tant qu'ouvrier agricole se comprend
c'est une agriculture saine et raisonnée
pour qu on puisse laisser une personne à
nos enfants pour notre génération future
qu'avez-vous à rajouter à dire aux
électeurs maintenant si vous devez vous
adresser directement à eux et bien
évidemment et lectrices et lecteurs ce
que nous vous demandons c'est de ne pas
confondre les les temps ce temps ce
n'est pas un temps municipal ce n'est
pas non plus refaire l'élection
territoriale c'est véritablement
aujourd'hui s'armer de représentants qui
siègeront dans un groupe suffisamment
fort suffisamment construit suffisamment
compétent pour faire bouger les choses à
l'échelle de la martinique c'est ce que
nous avons fait à l'échelle de la france
tout entière ce que nous avons fait
c'est constituer une armée qui va
pouvoir défendre les intérêts nous avons
des projets nous avons un programme nous
nous attaquerons en question sur le
territoire évidemment de la pauvreté des
sargasses de l'accès aux soins parce que
la sécurité sanitaire nous sommes dans
une insécurité perpétuel et la sécurité
sanitaire est importante donc il faut
nous donner aujourd'hui les moyens
d'aller défendre des hôpitaux de bonne
qualité pour la trinité qui doit de
redevenir un hôpital de proximité
moderne pour le françois également et
pour le lamantin également qui doit
retrouver ses lettres de noblesse et son
rôle majeur soigner soigner la
population voilà donc je vous demande le
11 juin de faire le bon choix ce choix
là je pense qu'il peut être nous nous
sommes motivés nous sommes engagés et
nous sommes surtout déterminé à
représenter les martiniquaises et les
martiniquais béatrice baylet et
jean-philippe où tous amis merci à vous
tous les deux
merci
[Musique]